didn't get the
conversion that's big
um that's gonna hurt we could have
squeezed out more but the angle was
funky this is still huge damage that's
all oh my god he needed more oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go baby [ __ ]
[Music]
oh see that was using it i like it let's
go baby oh my god
clip that three
uh zafina could still move but this this
situation that's all too cool
oh my god this is going to do a ton of
damage but guess the back turn plasma
bait
this big all too early on the 443 power
crushes through for some pressure he has
to chase though he's chasing
oh my god did he press something
oh my god he got hit before and he's
going to do a ton of damage
it's it's going to be a bad situation
he's going to have to deal with oh my
gosh this is huge oh my god still
anybody's game killing today's round
is he going to rate drive oh my gosh he
went under oh my god he's crazy
holy sh
two
oh no all with the life lead less than
30 seconds now this is so tense a bell
with rage and he's holding on to it he
charged oh my god that was so sick
what happened what are you doing oh my
god the game trying to remove the double
albatron that was cool bro he's gonna do
it oh he's gonna do it oh no
[Music]
oh
i forgot about that
i forgot about that too
holy crap you have
a laundry list of menu items he's
though down four down four three oh my
god
one pressure
four four three four pressure four four
two for your step where are you stepping
pressure
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
you